voilà guinée chouchou de la semaine
alors les potes vous avez envie de
parler de voir parce que on oublie
souvent que le chanteur s'est aussi des
gens qui chantent
ah oui et que la voir oui mais voilà
j'espère que tout le monde connaît
bangui
il est pas sorti pauvre con j'espère
qu'on est maintenant aretha franklin et
l'a sorti un album n'ya pas longtemps
avec des vieux standards de jazz qu'elle
n'avait pas sorti auparavant
je demande à tout le monde l'écouté
enfin la caméra qui on se rappelle que
je ne veux rien dire contre les
chanteuses françaises bon et là c'était
les souliers acquérir et tant de gens
mais puisque je parle de voir génétine
qui veut légère et la jane qui veut dans
ce gnt prononçant pas
aujourd'hui ont lieu à la salle au micro
[Applaudissements]
s'est incliné qu'en deux paniers en face
d'eux tient bien spéciaux besoin aux
fesses ou la fesse qui tiens je vais
fermer la fesse qui tient ou et voilà
etc voilà un ministre et non le deuxième
il est sorti à quelques tomes il faut
écouter la voir cette loi là parce que
c'est quelque chose
rendez vous sur ces grill sud commence à
les connaître
côté pile on est ravi c'est quoi ça ça
c'est combler vos jazz c'est un
saxophoniste anglais que tout le monde
connaît je crois bien sûr et et ses
chaînes orange devait être le remier
chanson oui et il faut surtout écouter
les oiseaux suis vraiment et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus